and now seven past winners of the Irving
Thalberg memorial award
Walter Maris
Steven Spielberg
George Lucas
so then
Norman Jewison
Warren Beatty
and Dino De Laurentiis
please welcome Tom Hanks
how are you guys good to see you mm-hmm
naming an award after Irving Thalberg in
the motion picture industry is the
equivalent to calling a Citizenship
Award to Ben Franklin or an engineering
honor at the Thomas Edison
it's the albergue shaped the art form
commonly called producing by running a
studio and by making films with a larger
vision than merely just getting the film
in the can and making a buck
Irving Thalberg guided movies in the
same way presidents guide policy as long
lasting important team efforts that when
done well affect millions for a long
long time periodically the Academy
defers to fate and the record by
awarding the Irving G Thalberg Memorial
to a producer of great creativity whose
body of work reflects a long-standing
quality of effort and end result and
tonight that means we are honoring John
Calley with the Ben Franklin I mean the
Thomas Edison oops I mean the Irving G
Thalberg personally we can all be late
members do the John Callie company of
artists but if you've been going to the
movies for the last 40 years you have
been under the influence of the artist
John Calley from face in the rain to
remains of the day those on stage
tonight are gathered in Thalberg name
each has been honored with the award and
each has guided films to profit and
importance and each has greatly inspired
the audience's of their films for a long
long time Walter Maris George Lucas Saul
Zaentz Norman Jewish and Warren Beatty
and Dino De Laurentiis gentlemen have
each made movies that ranked as the
finest and most important and timeless
films ever made so too has the 1986
recipient of
Irving G Thalberg who will tonight
accept the award on behalf of this
year's honoree John Calley ladies and
gentlemen mr. Steven Spielberg
thank you Tom thank you Tom
the seven of us standing together this
evening have all shared one remarkable
honor and tonight we share another as we
are privileged to accept this award on
behalf of a man who we wish dearly could
be standing up here with us this evening
mr. John Calley John is so deserving of
this honor and like Thalberg himself
John has done a brilliant job of wearing
two hats as a studio head and as a
producer of the highest standards -
John's many friends and family members
who are here tonight we offer our
heartfelt congratulations and to John
when you watch this at your home
tomorrow please know how proud all of us
are to welcome you to our ranks we are
sending you our respect and our love and
our congratulations to John Kelly
gentlemen our seven cats
and tonight's Oscar winners Lauren
Bacall Roger Corman and Gordon Willis
you
you